and then you're going to do four times
the X and four times the 10. if you add
two more years of compulsory maths after
gcses it'll equal a nation with better
numeracy skills according to the Prime
Minister as head of maths at this
Birmingham secondary amio Driscoll
doesn't disagree but she does question
the timing with strikes pay and funding
disputes currently the main issues
facing schools at this at this present
time I think you know maybe is that that
should be maybe further down the line
for discussion
um when there is such a big crisis at
the moment within the teaching
profession what should be the focus of
the government then I think definitely
um the retention crisis in teaching as
well and then the the fair pay and until
those concerns are resolved there are
doubts over whether the plans could work
there is already a chronic shortage of
maths teachers and with many schools
struggling to recruit as it is some
question who will teach all this
additional maths the Prime Minister
accepted it'll take time to train more
teachers up that says his plan is about
tackling what he describes as an
anti-maths mindset my campaign to
transform our national approach to maths
is not some nice to have
it's about changing how we value maths
in our country and changing the way our
education system works to deliver it so
that all our children get these vital
skills for Life what do you notice about
this what can we do to this it wouldn't
mean everyone has to do maths a level
and the details still need to be worked
out but rather than worrying about what
they'll be studying next year these
pupils are more concerned about strikes
affecting their exams I could be missing
on a lot of learnings on there
I feel like there's more important
issues than to be making students do
just extra tiers of maths like the
strikes and just everything else that's
going on
by moving the focus on to maths the
government risks appearing to be out of
step with what pupils parents and
teachers want to be talking about Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham